[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
love all things marin morris that's a
country superstar her new video for her
song humble quest the grammy winners
highly anticipated third album of the
same name is out today can't wait to get
it her humble quest tour begins in june
anthony mason spoke with morris last
week in nashville for cbs sunday morning
she talked about the album her two
grammy nominations this year and her
role as a rare country artist with huge
crossover hits
do you think of yourself as country
because you you've been willing to go
you crossed the line
i think in a lot of people's view
yeah
i've crossed the line
but
i feel like my fans and new fans
discover me through all these different
pathways and know that it's
it's
it's still marin at the end of the day
i think i'm always going to be a little
bit of everything and i've just learned
to like
stop apologizing for it
was there a time where you felt like you
had to apologize for it
i think it got to me after my first
record when you know i did
the middle and 80s mercedes was more pop
and
um
you know people saying like she's not
country like that used to really hurt my
feelings and
i totally agree with the idea that you
remember where you came from and honor
that but to be beholden and captive to
it
i feel like the art just ends up
suffering
oh maren morris list
maren morris good music is good music i
take her however we can get her but i
always like to see her and anthony
together nate this is like their second
or third interview
and they all they have quite a bond and
it's always a good conversation when the
two of them sit down and i love marin's
and we get to listen to the music right
now
because it's out we do yeah oh yeah
because it's coming out oh yeah i
thought you meant right now i'm like
where where okay got it got it got it
got it i played it in the commercial got
it got it all right you can watch
anthony's full interview with mary
morris on cbs sunday morning next
weekend on april 3rd that's grammy
sunday wishful thinking i was thinking
is marin going to walk it out we're
still thinking